what's up everyone Gary Steinman here
with Alex Aman CEO creative director of
Assassin's Creed unity we're standing in
front of the Assassin's Creed experience
at Comic Con 2014 tell us a little bit
about this when we make the parkour in
the game we actually call upon a lot of
experts you know we have Hollywood
stuntmen we have actual parkour experts
so we felt that would really be a really
cool opportunity not only to have them
perform stunts in our own Park work
horse to show people how close the
parkour in the game actually is to
reality but actually let them
participate and let them try out how
good of an assassin they are
we've got lines that are hours long for
people to try this course but we've even
had some big names come through any
names that you recognize yeah we have
casey who is actually the first female
to ever complete the city finals of
American Ninja Warrior and she ran
through the course she obviously holds
the record for it right now
you've also revamped the parkour in the
game to tell us a little bit about that
we have indeed he's completely revamped
parkour we actually redid it from the
ground up almost and it's focused on a
lot more freedom of movement a lot more
flow for that we've given the player a
whole new axis of control you can not
only Park her up that's input control
obviously but you can also input control
down so instead of just having to use a
leap of faith and a haystack to exit a
building to go down from a building but
you can still do you can actually keep
control and have that parkour going down
the whole way you move through the game
too that's also been changed you've got
multiple stances can you talk to us a
little bit about that we have and this
is something another one of our core
pillars stealth is something that we've
been looking at for a long time we've
been trying to figure out ways of you
know giving the player more control more
visibility on on that stealth approach a
little bit more precision more finesse
so we've incorporated a player input
stealth mode where you can actually
crouch you're more silent we also have
automated covers so you when you get
close to an object you'll snap the cover
again all of this is giving you more
freedom it's giving you more finesse
over the control of your assessment
even the cameras been improved right yes
before I had liked it in the previous
installments we had many different
cameras we had for example the low
profile camera the high profile we had a
fight camera now it's only one camera
but that camera has this sort of an AI
incorporated into it so it can
intelligently detect different
parameters and adapt
so essentially you by your actions
you're actually being the director of
your own camera all these improvements
are all there to help you become a more
powerful assassin exactly in the game
you play our know you're sort of going
through his adventure of starting from a
novice his journey to becoming a Master
Assassin and that's exactly when we're
also offering every player their journey
of becoming a Master Assassin